we are told graph a line with a slope of
negative two that contains the point
four comma negative three and we have
our little khan academy graphing widget
right over here where we just have to
find two points on that line and then
that will graph the line for us so pause
this video and even if you don't have
access to the widget right now although
it's all available on khan academy
see how you would think at least think
about how you would approach this and if
you have paper and pencil handy i
encourage you to try to graph this line
on your own before i work through it
with this little widget all right now
let's do it together so we do know that
it contains the point four comma
negative three so that's i guess you
could say the easy part we just have to
find the point four x is four y is
negative three so it's from the origin
four to the right 3 down
but then we have to figure out where
could another point be because if we can
figure out another point then we would
have graphed a line and the clue here is
that they say a slope of negative 2.
so one way to think about it is we can
start at the point that we know is on
the line and a slope of negative two
tells us that as x increases by one
y goes down by two the change in y would
be negative two and so this could be
another point on that line so i could
graph it like this as x goes up by 1 as
x goes from 4 to 5 y will go or y will
change by negative 2. so y will go from
negative 3 to negative 5. so this we
would be done we have just graphed that
line now another way that you could do
it because sometimes you might not have
pa space on the paper or on the widget
to be able to go to the right for x to
increase is to go the other way if you
have a slope of negative 2 another way
to think about it is
if x goes down by 1
if x goes down by 1 then y goes up by 2
because remember slope is change of y
over change in x so you could either say
you have a positive change in y of 2
when x has a negative one change
or you could think of it when x has a
positive one change y has a negative two
change but either way notice you got the
same line notice this line is the same
thing as if we did it the first way as
we we had x going up by one and y going
down by 2 is the exact same line